we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p our
voicemail line is made possible by our
good friends over at linguist linguist
is a language learning service that uses
fine tuned spaced repetition it's
powered by AI and it makes foreign
language vocabulary learning a breeze
i've been using it to improve my French
I've been really impressed with how much
I've improved since I've started using
linguist I haven't even been using it
that long about a month and a half you
can try it for free no credit card
needed at linguist calm slash Pakman
that's Ling Vista with a v.com slash
Pakman let's get to today's voicemail
take a listen
hi doing David um recently the rapper
cardi B video came out about her where
she talked about raping well not I'm not
season out reason she talked about
entitlement for sex then drugging them
and stealing their money and I had like
I hadn't really seen this me and talked
about like you mean like mainstream
media or anything like that
I was wondering if you thought if you if
this was a man that that you know came
on admittedly on video talked about
doing these kind of things do you
believe that ever had a bigger impact
you know anything would have been a it
was it would be a bigger story if a man
talking about doing these things that
she that he that he admitted to doing
you know I think it's possible that it
would be I looked a little bit about a
hip-hop artist R&B artist I don't know
what I'm supposed to call her rapper
cardi B and joking about having drugged
men I believe that she was a sex worker
at one point drugging them and then
taking their money I mean those are
crimes okay and I think it for me it's
not so much about its it would have been
a bigger deal if it had been a man
although that may be true it's that it
it should be a big deal when she says it
now you may be talking about listen I
don't know if she's telling the truth or
not sometimes people say things to get a
reaction but if she's saying that she
did this there are questions about the
statute of limitations I don't know if
it can be investigated but this is
really really serious and there should
not be a gendered reaction
I can't say for sure exactly who would
have reacted how based on the gender of
the I don't know but this is really
serious stuff and what she's talking
about here is criminal what she's
talking about it's criminal and it
simply cannot be written off as some
kind of joke and maybe I don't know
enough about the full scope of it maybe
there's some detail that explains why it
hasn't become a bigger deal than it has
and it may be that it's a long time ago
with nameless people and who knows if
there's even any possibility of
exploring in more detail what she claims
but I found it extraordinarily
disturbing we've got a great bonus show
today I'll tell you what's been going on
here in Las Vegas I had a not great
flight to Vegas yesterday actually and
I'll tell you about that on the bonus
show get instant access at WWE
pakman.com